investigators are trying to determine
the motive for the shooting the suspect
as you know is Dewayne Craddock he's a
40 year old engineer and a 15 year
employee of Virginia Beach he had
submitted a resignation email the day of
the attack Errol Barnett is outside the
crime scene Errol what else do you know
about this resignation well we know that
one of the deceased victims was in the
suspects chain of command but was not
his direct supervisor so that could be a
clue now as investigators try to
determine if the gunman's job status had
anything to do with what unfolded in
building two directly behind me he was
not terminated and he was not in the
process of being terminated officials
have not said what the suspects
resignation contained only that his job
performance was satisfactory he was in
good standing within his department
reports of gunfire first came in at 4:08
p.m. Friday two minutes later officers
arrived from police headquarters near by
navigating a building police described
as a honeycomb police eventually found
the suspect eight minutes later who
discharged rounds well into the double
digits in a prolonged gun battle at 4:19
one officer was shot saved by his
bulletproof vest
once cornered the gunmen exchanged fire
with police through a door then silenced
officers entered and administered first
aid but the suspect died later at the
hospital
police recovered two 45 caliber handguns
one equipped with extended magazines and
a silencer more weapons were found at
the shooters home all legally obtained
have the suspects family and relatives
been in communication with you guys our
team of detectives are out interviewing
everyone the suspects family did not
return our request for comment and
posted this message on their front door
the kradic's say they are grieving for
their loved ones sending condolences to
victims Sunday morning
each of the 12 victims could be seen in
the Craddock driveway staring back on
the front page of the newspaper now as
we mentioned all of the suspects weapons
were legally obtained and that includes
the silencer or what's known as a
suppressor last night President Trump
was asked if he thinks those silences
should be restricted and while he didn't
answer that question directly
he did say quote I don't like them at
all Tony
Errol thank you very much story so
disturbing on so many levels because it
keeps happening happening happening but
one thing that stands out to me they
keep saying this guy was well-liked
well-known nobody had any idea that he
was harboring this kind of thing what
scares me guys how do we protect
ourselves you can't and you don't know
what's good you you can't it's
inexplicable yes the other and you may
not ever get an answer for it is that
word for it that's the problem no answer
that would ever make sense even if you
get the answer that's right